new anti-israel protest breaking out in
New York City this as Republican
candidates call out the disturbing rise
of anti-Semitism on college campuses and
radical protesters who've been
terrorizing Jewish
students and we need leadership at the
top in the United States of America that
restores our founding values and that
has no place for this kind of
anti-Semitic hate and what is Biden
doing not only is he not helping the
Jewish students who are being persecuted
he is launching an initiative to combat
so-called
islamophobia no it's the anti-Semitism
that's spiraling out of control we are
about taking care of people not going
and making them live in fear because
some other terrorist activity says they
want to destroy them compare that with
the unhinged anti-Semitism spewing from
the Democrat Party recently censured
congresswoman Rashida TB got asked point
blank to explain what she meant when she
endorsed the pro slogan from The River
To The Sea which calls for the
eradication of Israel I'm asking my
colleagues don't distort the words of my
residents many people in this movement
for human rights for Palestinians have
always centered around coexistence uh
you hear them calling for that uh and
saying that you know no matter your
faith your ethnicity your background you
should be able to live uh without fear
without discrimination without this kind
of inequality that you know netanyahu's
extremist party and his leadership has
been pushing
and now radical Rashida's anti-semitic
comments are embarrassing America on the
world stage Brett Bear has an exclusive
interview with Benjamin Netanyahu
tonight at 6 PM the Israeli Prime
Minister is slamming tb's
comments are you surprised by all the
push back not just in the United States
with these protests but around the
world well the river to the sea from The
River To The Sea means there's no Israel
from the Jordan River to the
Mediterranean which is a tiny area by
the way uh that encompasses Israel there
is no Israel and so what uh this
congresswoman is calling for is pode and
genocide the elimination of the Jewish
State the one and only Jewish state of
the Jewish people so that's that's
absurd and I salute the Congress for
censoring her but it's beyond that I
think the protest that you're seeing I'm
sure it includes some naive people but
there are a lot of people who know
exactly what they're
saying all right Jessica yesterday we
talked about what she thought what we
thought she meant but today she was
asked specifically and she says that
from the river to the sea is actually
about peaceful
coexistence yeah I don't think so um and
if she really thought that it wouldn't
have taken her several days to prep that
answer right that's something if you are
part of the Palestinian community and
that is a phrase that you use so
regularly that's being chanted in your
community that you know how to explain
it so I maintain my position from yest
yesterday that I'm not buying it I also
think you know you run to a friendly
interviewer about it put out an op-ed do
interviews with everybody everyone who
wants to talk to me about this they want
to talk to me about my past comments you
made on The Intercept podcast um a few
years ago um talking about a one-state
solution and I'm pretty sure that her
one-state solution is not that Israel
rules over Gaza and Palestine it's the
other way around so I'm not into it um
it's interesting to hear Netanyahu talk
about what's going on here I think this
is the first time that we've heard
comment from him on it um and it really
speaks to the power and the import of
what's Happening Across America and in
huge metropoles like in London and Paris
and how disturbing it is especially for
the leader of Israel and I I'm no fan of
Netanyahu and his policies um but it
it's very striking to me to hear that
and that he called out
that there are for sure some people who
are naive but that he doesn't buy it
that most people don't understand and I
think that maybe we have been giving too
many hall passes to people who are
absorbed in their Tik Tok feeds and that
people do understand more than we think
about this certainly the faculties at
these universities and people's people
in positions of power and I just comp I
continue to be deeply disturbed by
what's going on you know Dana last night
the candidates talked about um how they
would handle the anti-Semitism that's
going on on the University campuses did
you have a chance to hear about what
their plans were I mean I W I listened
to the whole thing I think that all of
like part of it was about the Visas the
student visas that was once something
that you that will you'll get into a big
Free Speech debate on that but maybe
that's a debate worth having and and I
also think though that there is a deep
um I think maybe I can't remember which
one it was talked about just this is a
leadership issue I me i' been vake and
but I don't there was no disagreement on
the stage on many issues including this
one but Rashida TB she has no incentive
for this to end she's making a gazillion
small dollar contributions because she
was censured she's getting all the
attention that she could ever want her
people that support her they love this
moment so she has no incentive to stop
so that's not going to end I'm glad she
was censured the mass brawl outside of
the Museum of Tolerance is about as on
the nose for this moment than you could
possibly get those protesters went to
that venue on purpose because they
wanted to attack them the other thing is
can you imagine for a moment what it
would look like today if a Muslim man
had been murdered by some altright white
protesters forget it that's all we would
be talking about we'd be having a
national conversation right now about
all these ills instead the media is not
covering that at all and the protest
violence is pretty much consistently
coming from one side and it's not the
people who are accused of being the
oppressors you you know Greg what what
Dana referenced was that gal gdau
screening of the Hamas terror attack
which apparently she got the actual
video of what went on and why do these
people the Hamas people want so much to
suppress the reality of what happened
well they're living they're in order to
maintain the conflict in the past you
have to deny the present atrocity
because if you you can't say the you
have to have the hisor IAL context and
then you have to question whether this
really happened I'm noticing really
weird bedfellows young liberal white
women who daily reject the misogyny and
sexism of the patriarchy marching
alongside the most misogynous
anti-female men who had a brawl in front
of the Museum of Tolerance I would warn
to Liberal women the reason why they
haven't come for you yet is cuz they're
busy with the Jews uh but don't worry
they're going to get back to you and put
you in their place cuz there you know
Hamas isn't for equal rights in case you
didn't notice in my neighborhood what
sprung up uh I think it was last night I
just saw them posters all over of Gaza
victims right to which I say good for
you that's your right but guess what
they're still up young Jews so far
haven't been tearing them down that's
the contrast between delusion and
decency tearing down po posters is
caused by a delusion that denies the
atrocity so you can tear it down the
other is people who just want their kids
to get free and are okay with your
posters what you brought up it's amazing
how Paul kesler's death came and went
the details are still in dispute but it
was ruled a homicide but none of the
mainstream media seems to care about
that they're not picking it apart or or
analyzing the video of course if it was
a like you said if it was a young pro
Palestinian we'd be back to 2020 and on
CNN and MSNBC hearing about mostly
peaceful riots and then there will be a
a need to defund anything that is
related to Jews but because he's not a
member of the designated oppressed class
Paul Kesler vanishes much like the trans
killer Manifesto if it doesn't fit into
the
narrative there it goes all right Jesse
20 go ahead you want to talk go
ahead I would say this seven years ago
was
Charlottesville and there was a chance
Jews will not replace us and Joe Biden
and the Democrats seized on that chant
Joe Biden ran for president based on
that and they made everybody in the Maga
movement look anti-semitic remember when
you went like this in a picture that was
anti-semitic just the other day Hillary
called Trump Hitler they had articles on
NBC that going to the gym meant you were
a Neo-Nazi right and then really when it
was about saving lives when the rubber
hit the road and Israel was attacked who
circled the wagons around Israel it was
the entire Republican party immediately
did but large subsets of the left not
only didn't they circle the wagons they
sided with the people that attacked the
Jews and now you're seeing massive
protests by these people all over and
they're chanting some pretty nasty stuff
and I just remember if you're in a rally
let's say you went to Charlottesville
that day and you didn't want these
statues torn down for historical reasons
and the guy next to you chanting about
Jews will not replace this I might maybe
March the other direction and try right
no these marches they are not getting
thinner no these marches are building
and that tells me this is a growing
anti-semitic movement entirely on the
left and the Democrats and the media
cannot reconcile it because it doesn't
go with what they've been selling the
last eight years okay hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else